okay well welcome to what turns out to
be the 300th livestream meeting in this
series and this one is a language
completeness and consistency meeting
looking at features trying to make
everything perfectly unified and uniform
and Wolfram language so what we're
looking at here create intermediate
directories and overwrite target so I
think this is become slightly less
controversial sand since the last
meeting so we have some functions that
take both that create intermediate
directories and an override target
options then we have some that only take
an override target and then there were
some weird ones that also only took
overwrite target but but they meant
something different by that they meant
something different from it so their
current plan is to just pick a sensible
default and if they needed an option
they'll figure something else out in the
future okay but so there's no point and
create intermediate directories unless
you actually have named a file with a
directory in it correct correct
okay so these are really orthogonal
things there's there's like you name the
file but you need to actually be able to
dig down to get to that file and there's
a file already there should you
overwrite it there's a completely
orthogonal things right that's what's
really sort of you know the overwrite
target was sort of used as a marker for
things that possibly should also take
also a copy file for example probably
should also take a create intermediate
directories mm-hmm I would think I would
think for sure these ones should now why
is there an override target an audio
capture because those have file names in
them do they via a method option
so that they're kind of weird I mean
this is something right we're working on
with you know where where to store
things projects so maybe we don't touch
them for now but you can name a location
using a method that particular things
happened okay sorry
that that particular thing that just
happened of taking a long time to load
this audio capture thing that's another
issue that should be looked at because
that has to do with the fact that there
are giant audio things on this page
right so this one looks perfectly
civilized and and that looks like a
valid and I don't see why it shouldn't
have create intermediate directories as
an option here mm-hmm
I mean if create intermediate
directories is false and you specify a
deeper thing it's just gonna error out
isn't that correct correct okay fine I
mean that sounds highly sensible and
just a good way that we you know we
picked up that consistency
or what the heck is this where is the
file anyway it's in the method option
that's totally weird I mean that's
totally weird and crazy yes I don't know
I don't understand why speech
synthesized doesn't have I mean that's
just a bonkers place to put it well I
guess the idea is in most cases it picks
something sensible automatically I know
but it should have a persistence
location if that's what it right well I
mean this is part of I mean I don't want
to delve into this whole storage
location okay fine fine fine but I mean
that's oh we can leave this we
definitely don't want to mess around
with this right now I think this is
wrong but this is not the yeah okay fine
but I mean to me speech synthesiser
didn't already have an argument
structure like that would be best to
have a file argument just like audio
capture does if we really want I mean if
audio capture can justify it so can
speech synthesized I've put this in a
file I wonder if it's a matter of takes
an additional argument right well it
takes the voice that but I don't know
what it doesn't even say what the voice
what what are the voices look like are
they strings believe they're strings
yeah well that's not good is it
because yelder okay we can have yo zuzia
Wow okay all right I wonder
sixteen minutes a 16th person the
sixteenth clone or sixteen years old or
what the who knows okay oh I see it's
the same person who knows um well I
think there's something wrong with this
and I think that's that should be
separately handled is anybody from that
team on this meeting I don't think so
okay well I think they should separately
look at that but I think there's nothing
I think we've we've clarified what needs
to happen for these for these options
mm-hmm okay next up if we could listen
this one I really want make sure we get
to all right okay so this had a whole
zoo of possible linker II right well so
so on UNIX I think we understand and you
know you can create you know some bars
links and hard links and we more or less
understand that on Windows you as it
turns out you can't actually create
symbolic links unless your administrator
so it would fail most of the time so
it's not just enough that you're have
beyond Windows 10 you need to enable the
so called developer mode in order to be
able to create symbolic links without
being administrator okay do we have a
proposal for the function that's
operation that creates links at all so I
mean it would be just like we have copy
file it will be something like link file
that right right well so what Windows
supports I mean it does support these
things called hard links injunctions and
the but you know they have weird sorts
of restrictions relative to what one
might expect
sym likes to support all right but the
fundamental concept is link file from
file one to
file2 and then maybe there's an argument
that says the type of link well remember
links can like directories to fine okay
file one directory one whatever it is
well everything you called it link file
yeah I'm not sure it should be a link
file I think it should be more like
create link well what does copy file do
with directories nothing
it only copies files I don't think
that's correct I think you can copy a
directory deeply skeptical of that
statement you just made is there a
separate thing called copy directory yep
does that have a - I see okay hmm
I hate something like filesystem link
because I think that's a um I mean
helpfully Ln is called make links and
trustingly they talk about it as file in
their summary right so a hard link it
has to have to be files you can't hardly
into directory a symbolic link being
just a pointer can point to anything in
fact it doesn't even have to point to
anything that exists yeah I can point to
nothing
so that's sort of a fundamental
difference between hard links and
symbolic links well in a sense you know
link file is dealing with the common
case and to say footnote you can link
directories doesn't seem horrendous to
me well you can link directories some of
the time right exactly which is why link
file might be a good name for it maybe
it's what I would propose link file
file1 file2 default is a hard link by
the way we also presumably need unlink
don't we know because you delete links
using delete delete file yeah okay but
so file two in this picture doesn't
exist right correct so there's an
overwrite target option that's needed
here or isn't that a file to exists you
want to blow it away and say actually I
want file to to be a link to file one
yeah right I mean I don't think that's a
default to true no it should default to
false by the way there's there's another
oddity here which is that one might want
to specify a relative path name and
normally when we think of relative path
names in Wolfram language we think of
them relative to current directory but
for links it's relative to the where the
link is who is it is that what Ln does
really I believe that's true that seems
very weird to map and copy file could do
that too but it doesn't
Coffee file just takes it relative to
the whole paw I mean and the short
answer is there is this oddity so that
basically whenever I create a symbolic
link I always CD into the directory that
creates it so I won't get confused
because otherwise I get it wrong so
there is an oddity in here I just can't
tell you exactly what the spec is okay
well I would argue that whatever it does
copy files should be doing the same
thing and since copy file doesn't do
some weird relative thing I would think
this shouldn't either
well the I mean in the case of copy file
though it's I mean the issue here is
that you're actually embedding into the
link you know a relative path from you
know from where the link is and you and
you may want to be very precise about
how that gets written I mean oh gosh yes
I see what you're saying you you you you
don't want it you don't want to compute
an end absolute path that's actually
what you don't want because the link
when you move files around wants to
still stay somehow linked yes oh that's
a can of worms that is an unbelievable
what kind of work right so so the way L
n works is that file two is resolved
because that's where you're creating the
link and then file one is copied
literally into the result so that if you
without any canonicalization which so if
it's a hard link then that relative path
must correctly get you to the source and
if it's a symbolic link then it will
just point to where the first argument
points to relative to file two where I
guess the directory containing file two
to be precise
how long the live stream is asking it's
not clear where the delete file will
delete the link or the or the fault no
it would delete if you say delete the
name of file one then it will delete the
link if you say delete file two then it
will delete the file
- you know if you use the name of no no
if it is a link it will delete the what
do you tell you specify if it's a
linkage just to get the file which is a
little if it's a hardly at all I know I
know I know but what we're saying is
it's linking file one to file - right so
file two is the destination okay what I
mean is I type in the name of file one
it's called you know fish and that will
go - but what it will really pick up
when I say you know open fish if fish is
hard link to fowl then it will actually
open fowl right correct so if I say
delete file of fish it will delete the
link that links fish to foul it won't go
in and reach through the link and delete
fowl
oh yes yes it does not difference the
link yes and like some operations them
you're saying delete file doesn't
dereference the link but for example
open does dereference the link yeah now
presumably if we have this we also have
to have things like saying resolve the
link right how would you resolve the
link you're basically take the link and
you find the Lakeisha therefore past you
know but how do you do that as well and
and and you might not want to resolve
the link directly you might want to
resolve a path that has one or more
links in the path that's a useful thing
to want to do you think absolute file
name of /tmp right so that resolved that
symbolic link to what it actually points
to right
okay well so what's okay so I mean to me
all right what's what are the questions
that remain here right so I guess so if
we're defaulting to hard links and if it
is in fact the case that you can create
hard links without being an
administrator on Windows then I think
this is fine you know symbolic would be
you know that would be more problematic
on Windows yeah well so then probably
isn't work on Windows I mean I you know
I don't you know some more like links
are a creature of you know a modern UNIX
even when I started using UNIX they
didn't have symbolic links that was
those were added go-rounds one probably
in 1980 or something but right I can
certainly tell you that by by the early
90s they had symbolic links oh for sure
yes I think they were added sometime in
the around 1980 okay all right can we go
on I mean I think this is a reasonable
direction I think we should try to
implement this and see where it goes
the only other question is you know do
we want to have a mode for creating you
know shortcuts like you know in the
finder or in the that will be lovely
that will be lovely I would love that
I didn't know that was possible for a
program to do I thought you had to go
into the finder itself to do it I I mean
I think that's just creating a special
file I don't know exactly don't remember
the details because it's been a long
time supporter putting it on the shelf
and the finder and things go ahead I
mean it's certainly I can speak on
Windows it's certainly possible to
create them most things don't know what
to do with them okay fine actually yeah
I think you and Steven may be talking
about different things because I just
heard Steven talking about putting on
the shelf
which is that that's that's a different
concept I don't know what the Shelf well
well I mean for example I have these
things here oh yeah lots of some kind on
some shelf yeah I don't know how those
are implemented right there there's the
right you know if you drag something
across file systems or if you right
click you get a you know the option to
you know create a shortcut rather or
copy so there's a shortcut place to go
symbolic Glencoe is something different
it's something different it's all those
links do work fine in the finder that's
true yeah guys I mean go find out more
facts about this and come back to this
just just so you know I mean I use some
links for stuff that's linked to from
from my doc and works just fine so yeah
ok can we tackle something that I know
we need which is this edge cue question
um I don't think in a cosmic year I are
required for anything else here who are
not so feel free to great Mike okay yeah
um okay
the issue here
you
is that
see what what we've got
can you describe what the issue is this
years you're adding a tag to the edge to
an edge specification right not really
the point is you know HQ before we
actually added tag we're also used to
figure out if two basic two vertex I
just said right so now since we have tag
is no longer the case for tag edge so
the question is do we want a new
function it have not interested to do
with HQ because edge Q we define it like
you know the second argument is an edge
well I understand so this is basically
graph adjacent Q or vertex adjacent we
have adjacency lists already we have it
set of those adjacency for so maybe just
one you want so vertex vertex what would
it be called should be normally
something close to adjacent vertex Q's I
believe it should be adjacent vertices Q
but yep this is okay but then the for
that would be graph and then vertex 1
vertex 2 is that right well should it
should it be and and what would happen
if we just called it adjacent queue that
obviously wrong there's also address no
we have adjacency matrix you have a
decent list so if I mother part of the
system doesn't need it is fine I think
given that we call this adjacency we
don't even want to talk about vertices
we just call it adjacent queue okay let
me raise a different issue so somebody
was complaining about the fact that you
used to be able to take an edge and just
safe lost of it to get the second
you know vertex on the edge right is
that correct yes yes okay so can we go
over that please for a minute okay what
what is that that you can take what is
the construct that you can take blast
off to get currently before tagging what
is that construct of what so what so
essentially you want the list of
vertices for a night of an edge right so
that's a fair way to do it you can
wonder what was that what was the thing
that people were complaining would stop
working because of tagging could you
answer that question please so that was
doubt that is HQ as far as I know so
that was a complaint that now as she
will not work for tagged edge is not
stopping working he will still work how
do you okay a tagged edge what it what
is it what what do we call this what
what is the thing is undirected edge we
taster document okay that's the problem
that's the problem that undirected edge
now has the third argument right yes and
does directed
also have a third argument yes okay
so let's not beat around the bush that's
the problem the problem is you can no
longer go in and ask for undirected edge
part two of undirected edge and expect
to get the destination right again how
the campaign was last the person was not
using part two he was using last okay
with that but that's all hackery
I mean okay so how would I get nice and
cleanly so do vertex vertex list of why
that that exists of that on tonight at
aged so vertex list is normally applied
to a graph but can be applied to an
individual edge yes actually prior to
version twelve one if you put a list
around it it works because we support
even holes will work so it can put the
list of holes I mean the question is it
seems to me a pretty common thing to
want to get the beginning of a directed
edge and saying first the vertex list
seems kind of icky adding you know we
also kind of run away from that adding a
new force on just for that also seems to
be too much I agree I mean there's a sub
value for directed edge like start and
end no what's that I know we don't I
know we don't have it we could have it I
don't know whether I like that okay
let's throw this into okay let's talk
about hypergraphs say so
max here has been working on hyper
graphs this max here yes
okay so we were starting to make a list
I know whether you want to impress
people with some random hypergraph demo
um but basically you
hyperedge okay hyper edge is a list of
vertices with the symmetry specification
right okay - Charles you understand that
right somehow what symmetry mean okay in
a in an undirected edge you can as well
go from six to five is from five to six
what okay and a directed edge you can't
in a hyper edge the question is when you
come into the hyper edge from vertex a
do you go to you know can you go to
which vertices do you go to oh that's a
different issue that's a issue of where
you where you can go is different from
the issue of reach
arrangements of criteria identified in
each other fair enough Charles how would
you make the same distinction for
ordinary graphs or not well I think here
we are trying to assign the property to
this subset of the edge as far as I know
you can have a directed hyper edge or
undirected hyper edge no no no wait a
second wait a second wait a second wait
a second wait a second no you're not
addressing the issue so what max just
said is there are two different meanings
one is you know you're routing into an
edge out of an edge etcetera right the
second case is the identification in the
graph for graph isomorphism okay of
which edge is equivalent to which other
edge right for graph isomorphism a graph
that has you know two nodes a and B and
directed edges that go from A to B both
go from A to B is a different graph than
one where one edge goes from A to B and
the other goes from B to a right
right but if those were undirected edges
those two of the same graph
yes okay so similarly for a hyper graph
you can have symmetries at the hyper
edges of the hyper edges what what I
mean is that that's one way to see it
and that shouldn't probably the case the
way we added to the system what because
I say that's one way to see it right
yeah well not necessary the way to
actually add it in the system or extend
the current functionality why because
those symmetry property are you
essentially you're adding an additional
information to the edge which is not
necessary right to edge just purely
describe you topology or the
connectivity without any additional
property but it does have an it's like a
directed with an undirected edge but
there is non be gritty when you try to
resolve it is the contest where you try
to resolve it like when you decide to do
isomorphism no wait wait wait a second I
don't understand what you're saying
there's two issues one is routing
through the network okay and there one
can
have an arbitrary so one can have
arbitrary routing through a hyper edge
right you come into one one node of the
hyper edge which nodes do go out from in
the case of a of an ordinary edge a
binary edge
directed hyperedge and you're going down
the one-way street the wrong way you
don't go you see what I'm saying yes
right so in a hyper graph you can come
in one side and there could be any given
there is essentially a little graph that
defines inside the hyper edge there is a
graph that defines where you can go
right
isn't that correct max but my point is
that no you are specializing your hyper
graph or your hyper edge so there's no
point yes but just like an ordinary
graph you specialize into a directed
graph in an undirected graph what's your
point well my suggestion was does that
should we shouldn't probably do that in
our design but leave that freedom or
that no that can't work the functions
will depend on whether it's a an ordered
or directed hyper graph or not just like
they do for a for a graph right it means
something different it's got to be
different it's not useful to have a
hyper graph that doesn't allow those
possibilities
just like it wouldn't be useful to say
oh well because we don't feel like it
we're not gonna put directed graphs into
the system that would be silly right no
no I don't use that but what I mean is
that we are making a specialization of
forms I mean what specialization are we
making we say me no no no no no no no no
no no no look the general case I suspect
is that there is a graph that represents
the relationship between the nodes in a
hyper edge okay I suspect that's the
most general way to think about it and
that graph has some autumn orphism group
and that is the symmetry associated with
that hyper edge do you think that's
correct
for example if it was the complete graph
then that would mean that this is a
completely undirected hyper edge if it
was a graph that is just sort of a a
daisy chain from one vertex to another
in the hyper edge then that is a
different kind of thing but I think that
they the graph inside the hyper edge is
what defines I claim both connectivity
and symmetry max what do you think looks
like okay anybody else
Jose anybody else here has an opinion
about this so you know I'm not
sufficiently expert in in hypergraphs no
but is is that second argument really a
general symmetry I mean can you put an
arbitrary permutations not a symmetry
that the search is the wrong idea but
that second argument really there is
essentially a um that that's itself a
graph and that that graph operates on
these on those vertices to determine the
structure to determine what's allowed
and we probably would want certain
things like hyper edge you know um you
know ABC maybe we have a thing
undirected here or something like that
so little acid naively if it's a cuff so
why do we need a and D because this is a
single edge ice what you're saying
well because minute look look because no
no those are okay you're saying every
hyperope graph you can think about a
hyper graph as being about whether
somebody's is not on mute and is making
a noise um the you can think of
a hypergraph as being a bunch of nodes
where I can suppose you can imagine that
there's a graph at every edge of the
graph
let's see this is slightly confusing
never go ahead so for me a hyper graph
essentially instead of a binary
operation you have a an array operations
and depending on the specialization of
the graph now what you can do like you
suggest that you can have a symmetry you
can say well those that set also is a
sub graph or is a graph or it have
certain set of property so that's kinda
saying it's a relation where it could be
if it's a binary relation there are only
two kind of possible relations namely
the undirected and the directed you know
but we don't put any restriction on the
top of the relations
maybe later down the hall Dwight we can
specialize it where we have you know
specific type of relation we're waiting
I mean here for example with the tagging
that's effectively defining a type of
relation no the tagging is just a naming
scheme well they find that the the
relation is that five I know what you
mean by relation here I mean 5 goes to 6
and or in the undirected case 5 and 6
you can go from one to the other
ok so
what's your point I mean so in
Graff instead of associating two nodes
you're associating n nodes yes it's a
blob of the collection of notes sure
right but the question is when you do
Graff operations on that hyper graph
what do you assume about those notes for
example let's say that you are you know
routing information through the hyper
graph okay you come in to an edge and in
the case of an ordinary graph
you either can go either way on the edge
or you can just go one way on the edge
here you come in to port one and you
might go out to port two or to port
three or you might only go from port one
to port 2 and so on right yes okay so I
believe that that connectivity is
defined by a graph that lives inside the
hyper edge but it's still in terms of
adjacency every node in the hyper edge
is considered adjacent to every other
node in the hyper edge
like that's one way to see it yes but
one thing one could always do is to puff
out each hyper edge into the little
graph that represents the connectivity
of that hyper edge so my point is that
we cannot assume that it is a little
graph is when you think about housing or
a certain type of a parish on that you
know do you look at that's you know
those that subset into hyper edge as a
graph it's appropriate but somewhat
operation is not well give me an example
isomorphism for example
well as a morphism in principle it
returns to appropriate okay so it's
still appropriate I mean to look at a
Ziggler but they say maybe in some other
case it doesn't have to be that well
let's figure it out let's figure it out
because because the question here is the
thing I'm pushing on right I don't want
to make a mistake as we add this tagging
to edges here and cause a bunch of
trouble with people you know right
I mean I'm missing sorry I'm missing the
point I don't see why the tagging will
create a problem
okay we just went through this people
thought that this that edges had two
arguments no it's one person Caesar so I
don't think it's just one person
I'm guarantee they'll be code the brakes
as a result of this no you can't we are
using it we are introducing it new
inverse on 12 and you don't generate on
on the right a third edge unless you
oxidize in species you know we have a
set of constructors it can there is no
backward compatibility
Canberra is fine fine all right okay
okay this is a considerate a wake-up
call to make sure that we're specifying
edges in the correct way
okay but because what I want to do is to
introduce the hypergraph construct like
graph that many graph operations are
simply overloaded on and it seems that
most of these golf operations just work
yeah we kind of thought about that at
the time you know - you know when what
are we going to do with hypergraph right
so that was close to that you know if
we'd want to add it then we just need
time to sit and really work to the
designer look at all the possible cases
I understand but I want to understand
this because we are adding at least in
the functional process really are gonna
add a bunch of hypergraph stuff okay so
I want to understand whether the hyper
graph that we're adding at least is
compatible as best we can see it with
all these functions right so the concept
of the hyper graph is instead of being a
list of directed edge undirected edge
there'll be a list of hyper edges right
yes okay so then the question is of
those hyper edges there is clearly more
diversity than just directed versus
undirected yes
okay the particular hyper graphs that we
happen to be most interested right now
in our ordered hyper graphs that have
the property that the nodes can be
thought of as being in a definite order
one two two three
that make sense yes right so were we to
do routing through that graph right then
is that one concept I don't own this
town by odwin do you mean easy path or
by all the way you mean just is the
property of that set in the hyper edge
if is the property of this edge in the
hyper edge I don't see how will affect
tough
max do you want to say something about
this is your hypergraph plot too thin
working well right now nice work the
same as before so by order do you mean
like in that case you know ABC order do
you mean you have an edge you know you
have a putt a goes to B because to see
yes yes so a way to represent that in a
typical random okay this is a nice big
one of these ordered hypergraphs okay so
that's a node and this here is a hyper
edge this ordered hyper edge thing okay
so we could also have a cyclic hyper
edge where the thing closes on the other
side here okay so I mean the thing that
seems to me to make sense is that you
specify this thing right so each
operation I mean I think it's gonna be
okay I think that this is the correct
form now the second argument here
probably there are a bunch of string
names that correspond to the common ways
that those nodes can be related
that makes sense
so like I pick off the hypergraph rapper
can have a second argument which
basically says what the default relation
just like we have directed graph an
undirected graph right that makes sense
yeah okay I I'm just trying to check
that we're not doing anything here with
the design of hyper graph for this
inconsistent with what we have so far
or whether things we're adding with
tagging for example or inconsistent with
what we're doing with hyper edge my view
for hyper hyper graph was essentially
that we introduced hyper edge we have
essentially to type the height a
directed hyper edge an undirected hyper
edge one which take one said otherwise
we take two sets and we don't introduce
a new head hyper curve on curve just
contain the same thing sorry sorry sorry
sorry sorry I lost this you say we don't
introduce a separate hyper graph head
yes I don't think that's going to work
it's coffee what we do now we don't make
a distinction between a tea a pod coffee
well we are gonna make a distinction
with the tree we're going to have an
explicit tree wrapper soon which is a
cuff and we are not building it now what
what it's not a graph it's a tree okay
you can turn it into a graph if you want
to by saying tree graph right so but
what I'm saying is that in term of graph
white graph have seen well structures
wait when we did a design we decided to
not introduce a specific height for each
of those structures no and that's the
right thing however I predict that hyper
graph is different there has enough
different things see I don't think it's
gonna be the case that we can just go
boom boom boom boom boom down all of
these and have it work okay that's why I
was trying to inventory which ones does
it work for which ones does it not work
like a random graph I don't think we
want a graph distribution that
correspond that produces hyper graphs I
think that's a separate thing well we
need some time to think about it to a
framework is extensive and not that it
I know what I see I need I need some
time to see come on yeah yeah yeah right
okay so I predict what's gonna happen is
most graph functions are going to extend
to hyper graphs easily okay but some
will not
I mean I take your point that we might
be able to get away with graph for the
hyper edge inside it I doubt it though
but we'll see I mean you can also look
at it vertically some people Joseph
hyper graph is just a binary graph we
can always map it back tree graph is
just see since article sugar body said
in type of cough well it's not really
because if you mapped it to a graph you
would end up with different information
about the number of edges it has
etcetera etcetera but what I mean that
interpretation we can always apply it is
20 put some operations for domain
I understand that but we still need a
rapper that has um you know that
correctly counts edges and things
alright anyway max is gonna work on
trying to inventory what parts of the
graph framework you know won't extend to
hyper graphs but I think it's an
important point the hyper edge
specification
you know the part with the second
argument which is the string write it
one of the key feature of Goff it's you
know dotto visualization the night
typesetting when you generate the bunt
off on the right at the edge or the
right at edge having a hyper edge we D
string I'm not sure first how you are
going to type said that you know how
nice you will be in output and we don't
care about the hyper edge itself it
doesn't matter
the hyperedge itself I'm not concerned
about I mean it's the thing built into a
hypergraph that I care about but
somewhat palatial we turned him I mean
that is that part which is also for
sense yes and how did he typeset how did
he look rd readable well I understand
that I understand so the problem is that
just like we have directed edge and
undirected edge right for hyper edges we
have much more freedom than that right
I'm it's the first time I find this
concept of hyper edge so I was reading
about it while you were talking it seems
what I see that the concept is to have
two subsets one called tail set in the
other head set so among the members of
the hyper edge it's just a matter of
deciding which they must be disjoint
which one's belong to the head which
one's tail and they sort of freedom
because you have subsets there what
you're saying ok so what's that
I mean it's just a special case of it I
would think so yeah the thing you just
described with heads and tails that's
not the only possibility for what
happens inside the hyper edge
alright okay fine look I think I'm
satisfied that the stuff we're gonna do
for the function repository is not going
to be problematic
and we'll try an inventory what will be
involved and numb
yeah okay all right okay we have sort of
run out of time but is there something
quick we can do here
one I think maybe we it can be
reasonably quick so right so the
documentation for an active claims that
inactivates all heads which is a lie and
you know what does it actually do well
it activates all heads that don't match
the things in so so so go to the source
ref page because that'll so those two
notes explain what it actually does
whoo so what's the point here so it
doesn't inactivate list for example yep
it doesn't inactivate things that are
thought to be inert anyway pretty much
okay but so foo is thought to be inert
anyway is that the point right no it
didn't activate the point is that right
so in this particular case the the bug
report and the the very angry complaint
I got from Dennis Schneider is that it
doesn't inactivate graphics because
graphics is inert I mean with why did he
want it to inactivate graphics basically
because he wanted to disable the
typesetting of it because that's not
what an activate does and that rate is
about evaluation yes but since we don't
have any formatting rules of four
inactive of graphics than if you have
and enact okay so fine so that's a
that's a hacky use of of that for that
purpose I mean in this case right I mean
that's the OP
that way around that's getting
formatting right because there for you
know a small number of in particular of
mathy things which was the intended
application domain we we did put in the
effort to add formatting for inactive
okay which coat food doesn't mean
literally foo you know okay what I would
do in here fine we should add such a
note but we should say that things which
are which do not have evaluation rules
associated with them right are not
inactivated I mean that's not
it's almost true yeah I mean in reality
there's some internal things that cap
them even with rule but things that do
not have ordinary evaluation lots of
things which don't have evaluation rules
that aren't activated like what well
okay so then we have to say built-in
functions that don't have evaluation
rules that's like for example what would
happen if I said you know it's really a
specific list right I mean what is the
if I say it isn't that doesn't that I
know what would give me a sum operator I
don't know circle x or something yes I
see that inactivates that right right so
it's really patterns list because we
don't want to join a structure and then
data containers like Association it must
be must be among those heads to it
association why don't we get a list of
what we actually don't we
now do you have a list it's right there
look at the link developer dollar you
know it's stored in a variable that's
users edible so if you just evaluate
that variable you know what come in the
box but anyway because you copied also
the links or created a hyperlink of the
result
how freaking weird I think you wanted to
copy the the hyperlink not the address
but I see I wasn't really intended to
but I did it anyway what do you mean by
symbol rule
what does that mean well it's documented
so the the symbol the symbol exclusions
are the ones where it it skips the head
but goes inside and it activates the
contents and the expression ones are the
ones where it skips it it's kind of a
no-entry yeah god I've known
idea this looks like a giant hack tower
I mean do we think this list is
reasonably complete we think it's
reasonably complete for the purposes for
which it was created and its users
edible so well it's not we're not going
to document that setting up that way
it's simply not I mean unless it's some
kind of system option but that's gonna
blow up code like crazy alright listen I
think we need to pick this up at a
different time I mean it looks kind of
horrifying I think you can at least make
a comment for now that certain
structural operations such as list rule
and blank are not inactivated but keep
it vague oh my gosh like is regular
polygon and activated polygon is is
inactivated but regular polygon is not
no it probably shouldn't be oh I don't
know this looks like a horrible mess ok
this is a good LCC topic but we haven't
resolved it here I will point out that
other and activate exclusions is
documented
the developer context okay let's pick
this up another time okay okay all right
see you guys soon